dans l'actualité aussi le gouvernement
qui relance sa politique industrielle la
semaine dernière la création de 124
territoires industriels ont été annoncés
dont cinq en bourgogne est la bourgogne
franche comté qui on sait peu à la
région qui compte le plus d'emploi
industriel en pourcentage le détail tout
de suite avec les manuels par sono la
bourgogne franche comté est tout
simplement la première région
industrielle de france du point de vue
de l'emploi 17 % des salariés de la
région travaillent dans l'industrie
ils sont répartis dans près de 15000
établissements industriels
c'est la métallurgie et la fabrication
de produits métalliques qui emploient le
plus de salariés
viennent ensuite la fabrication de
matériel de transport de denrées
alimentaires
puis la fabrication de produits en
caoutchouc ou en plastique ces cinq
secteurs là regroupe 56 % des effectifs
de l'industrie 56% c'est aussi le taux
d'emplois industriels regroupés sur
seulement cinq grands secteurs
géographiques
le secteur de dijon d'abord avec plus de
190 mille emplois le secteur de belfort
montbéliard héricourt celui de besançon
d'auxerre et enfin le secteur de chalon
sur saône